Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
4%.
4%, c’est la proportion d’information
à laquelle nous avons accès
via les moteurs de recherche, de manière
facile, en tapant quelques mots clés
pour pouvoir trouver une information.
4%, c’est beaucoup,
mais c’est très peu à la fois
puisque ces 4% sont parfois pollués par
la génération des contenus artificiels -
ChatGPT,
parfois modifiés,
lors de la désinformation,
volontairement ou involontairement,
et puis souvent orientés par
les algorithmes des moteurs de recherche
ou des réseaux sociaux.
À une époque où chaque propriétaire
de téléphone portable
possède dans la main une caméra, un micro,
où chaque événement sur Terre peut être
retransmis en direct au monde entier,
Il est important de se poser la question
de savoir comment,
dans cette vague d’informations
que nous recevons tous les jours,
nous pouvons faire la distinction
entre ce qui est vrai
et ce qui est faux.
Einstein nous a dit un jour :
« L’intelligence n’est pas
de stocker l’information,
mais de savoir où la trouver. »
L’OSINT, l’Open Source Intelligence
est aujourd’hui une méthodologie,
une compétence qui peut s’apprendre
sans être un informaticien chevronné,
sans être un programmeur ou un enquêteur,
et va nous permettre
de pouvoir trouver l’information
en sources ouvertes, c’est-à-dire
des sources librement accessibles,
légalement évidemment,
et de pouvoir collecter une information,
analyser cette information
pour pouvoir la réutiliser.
Le but étant de répondre à une question,
de faire un choix
ou d’éclairer une pensée par exemple.
On va travailler sur cette masse
d’informations non accessible facilement -
ces 96% d’informations
qu’on appelle le deep web -
sur lequel nous allons
avoir besoin d’outils
et besoin de méthodes
pour trouver cette information.
Pour comprendre à quel point
tout ceci n’est pas toujours simple,
il faut comprendre
comment vit l’information.
L’information, elle naît, elle grandit,
elle est mature et ensuite elle est amenée
potentiellement à disparaître.
L’information, elle naît d’un fait, elle
naît d’une parole, elle naît d’une rumeur.
C'est le moment où elle est assez fragile.
C'est le moment où elle est assez unique.
Il est facile de remonter à sa source
puisqu’elle elle vient d’apparaître.
Mais c'est aussi le moment
où elle est en danger.
Je me suis promené hier soir en faisant
ma veille quotidienne sur l’actualité
et je suis tombé sur cet article.
Je vous laisse en prendre
connaissance quelques secondes.
« Le Conseil d’État a décidé,
pour des raisons économiques,
de faire des économies
sur le jet d’eau genevois
en réduisant sa hauteur
de 140 mètres à 60 mètres. »
Est-ce utile ? Est-ce judicieux ?
Est-ce le bon moment ?
Telle est la question.
Soixante mètres, vraiment ? Vous rigolez ?
Ce n’est pas -
Vous pensez bien que
cette actualité n’est pas vraie.
Je l’ai fabriquée de toutes pièces
hier soir, en préparant cette session.
Elle n’est pas totalement fausse,
elle n’est pas 100% fausse.
Je suis reparti d’une actualité
qui datait de la fin de l’année dernière
où effectivement les autorités ont décidé
d’étudier la possibilité d’économiser
de l’énergie sur le jet d’eau
en réduisant simplement
les horaires et non la hauteur.
Mais vous voyez qu’en quelques clics -
il n’est pas nécessaire d’être un grand
technicien pour faire ce genre de choses -
j’ai transformé une information
qui est 100% vraie,
issue d’une source réputée,
La Tribune de Genève,
ou une information 100% fausse,
même si à quelques détails près,
c’est-à-dire une date, quelques mots,
je n’ai pas changé grand-chose
pour passer de 100% vrai à 100% faux.
C’est tout le danger
de l’information naissante,
c’est le moment où elle est fragile,
c’est le moment où il est facile
de la créer et de la modifier.
L’information va ensuite grandir,
elle va évoluer,
un petit peu comme un virus.
Elle va s'adapter, elle va muter,
elle va être retranscrite.
Vous allez la lire, la reposter,
la commenter dans les réseaux sociaux,
la presse va la reprendre,
les robots vont la reprendre.
Cette information va s’amplifier.
C’est le moment où elle va
être complètement déformée.
Peut-être qu’après-demain, certains
sachants bien informés expliqueront
que ce n’est pas 60 mètres,
mais 40 mètres, le jet d’eau.
On n'est pas à l'abri.
C’est le moment où l’information
est difficilement contrôlable,
où elle se multiplie, où il est difficile
de remonter à sa source
parce que ça va très vite.
Internet va très vite, vous le savez.
Donc c’est un moment généralement
où il faut être prudent
vis-à-vis de l’analyse de l’information.
Puis il va arriver un certain temps
où l’information va devenir mature,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle va être acceptée
dans un certain état par le grand public.
Un état vrai ou un état faux,
c’est possible dans les deux cas.
Et c’est le moment où -
Qui dit maturité ne dit pas
nécessairement stabilité.
Il peut arriver que dans le temps,
certaines remises en cause
puissent ponctuellement venir
faire vaciller un petit peu ces vérités
acceptées de quasiment tout le monde.
En 2023, un sondage
Ipsos-Fondation Jean-Jaurès
nous donne l’information suivante :
« Un jeune sur six en France
croit que la Terre est plate. »
Un jeune sur six croit en France
que la Terre est plate en 2023.
Ça peut faire sourire.
Je vois des sourires,
des haussements de sourcils,
des haussements d’épaules.
C'est sûr que le sujet
n'est pas dramatique.
Croire que la Terre est plate ne
va pas changer la face du monde.
Ce n’est pas très important,
c’est trivial.
Sauf que dans cette même étude,
on a un jeune sur trois
qui pense aujourd’hui
que l’astrologie est une vraie science,
qu’on peut avorter avec
des tisanes faites à base de plantes,
ou que les photographies
de la tuerie de Boutcha en mars 2022
sont des mises en scène
des autorités ukrainiennes.
Et là, c’est beaucoup moins amusant.
L’information, il lui arrive
également de disparaître.
Elle va sortir des algorithmes,
passer de la lumière à l’ombre,
elle va quitter le clear web,
elle va passer dans le deep web,
un endroit où elle n’est pas -
Elle ne meurt pas l’information,
elle est plus difficilement accessible.
Pour y accéder, il va falloir
à un moment donné avoir des outils,
avoir une méthodologie
pour pouvoir la retrouver.
Et ça, ça va nous servir,
quand on est confronté
à un besoin de vérifier quelque chose,
de savoir comment trouver
ces anciennes informations.
C’est là que l’open source intelligence -
intelligence au sens anglophone
du terme : renseignement -
va nous donner des outils,
une manière de faire, des sources
d’informations très diverses,
qui vont nous permettre
d’exhumer cette information
pour pouvoir ensuite la réutiliser.
En tant que citoyen
d’un pays démocratique,
j’ai accès à tous ces outils,
à toutes ces données.
Ce n'est pas le cas de tous sur Terre.
Mais j’ai également le devoir aujourd’hui
d’utiliser ces informations
pour simplement m’assurer
que ce que je suis en train de lire,
je peux me l’approprier,
je peux le rediffuser.
C'est un devoir.
En tant que père de famille, en tant
que professionnel de la cybersécurité
ou en tant qu’enseignant,
Je porte même
une responsabilité aujourd’hui
quand j’acquiers une information
et que je vais la retransmettre à mon
fils, à mes clients ou à mes étudiants.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai
la nécessité de m’assurer
que ces informations
qui parviennent jusqu’à moi
et vont rebondir sur ma personne
puissent être simplement vérifiées
avant d’être retranscrites.
Alors, c’est vrai,
ça va demander un effort.
Ce n’est pas facile, on n’a pas toujours
le temps de vérifier l’information.
Ça demande de faire un petit effort
pour vérifier l’information
avant de pouvoir s'en resservir.
Mais à force de le faire,
on va passer de l’effort à l’habitude,
de l’habitude au réflexe.
À partir du moment où on commence
à vérifier l’information par réflexe,
on est clairement dans un mode
d'émancipation démocratique.
Le devoir d’être critique,
le devoir de vérifier l’information
avant de se l'approprier.
L’Open Source Intelligence
nous donne des outils.
C’est un des outils parmi d’autres,
mais c’est quand même un outil
qui va nous permettre
d’accéder à une émancipation
démocratique et informationnelle.
Quand vous allez rentrer chez vous,
vous allez certainement allumer la télé,
votre smartphone, tablette, ordinateur,
et que vous vous souviendrez
de ce chiffre -
un jeune sur six aujourd’hui croit
en 2023 que la Terre est plate -
posez-vous cette question :
« Et vous ? Et nous ?
Quel rôle pensons-nous
jouer face à cela ? »
(Applaudissements)